we've said it a million times but a
bear's repeating money is not just
numbers and math a dollar bill doesn't
have any value in itself it's a symbol
of human values what we want who we
trust what our priorities are how you
decide to spend it or save it can be a
window into your hopes and dreams but
also your fears and traumas
the point is money is intrinsically
emotional we can try to be as rational
as possible when making financial
decisions but your brain is not a
spreadsheet besides good financial
decisions should take your emotions into
account what would be the point of money
if it couldn't make you happy but
sometimes our emotions can hijack our
financial decision making in a way that
is recurring and self-destructive when
someone slips into such a pattern it's
known as a money disorder there are many
different types with different causes
and negative impacts you might recognize
one in someone you know or yourself
[Music]
in their book mind over money financial
psychologists brad and ted klontz
divided money disorders into three main
categories money avoidance money worship
and relational money disorders money
avoidance refers to people who for one
reason or another are made very
uncomfortable by the idea of money and
go to dangerous lengths to escape the
topic the most common type is financial
denial often spurred by income loss
overwhelming debt or other financial
woes
those suffering from financial denial
avoid all reminders of their money
problems this can mean never checking
their account balances ignoring credit
card statements and in extreme cases
neglecting bills or not filing their
taxes obviously you can only pretend for
so long eventually reality will assert
itself and the longer you've had your
head in the sand the worse the
consequences will be a bad credit score
is the least of your worries you can go
bankrupt get audited even evicted in
trying to avoid the emotional pain of
facing your money problems you've just
made those problems much much worse a
less common but still damaging form of
money avoidance is known as financial
rejection if someone has low self-esteem
gaining money can trigger feelings of
guilt and worthlessness they may
deliberately avoid steps that most of us
would consider financially smart like
asking for a raise or making long-term
investments they may also give their
money away to family friends or
strangers
that doesn't sound so bad noble even
after all many of our cultural and
spiritual heroes rejected the pursuit of
money sure if you make a conscious
choice to give all your possessions away
and live a monastic life we're not gonna
say that's not a valid life choice but
if you're doing it out of compulsion to
avoid negative emotions about yourself
that may be a disorder and you may put
your and your family's financial
well-being in serious jeopardy along the
way
on the other end of the spectrum is
money worship which describes people who
rely on money to alleviate emotional
pain or anxiety for example most of us
have occasionally spent a little more
than we intended or bought something we
regretted but compulsive shoppers use
the act of purchasing as a temporary
relief from feelings of depression or
anxiety it may feel great when the
credit card is being swiped but once the
shopping spree is over and you're back
home with all the stuff you know you'll
never use the negative emotions set back
in even worse than before with a hefty
credit card bill to boot
compulsive gambling is one of the few
money disorders officially recognized by
the american psychiatric association
diagnostic and statistical manual and it
doesn't just happen at the casino or the
race racetrack an addiction to the risk
reward dopamine cycle can be gratified
by lottery tickets stock trading even
video game loot boxes for compulsive
gamblers the thrill of winning is so
intoxicating that they're even willing
to risk their family's livelihood for it
and the pain of losing is so great that
the only thing that can alleviate it is
to chase the high of winning again
earning and saving are generally
considered to be positive financial
behaviors but even they can be taken too
far workaholics get so anxious when
they're not working that they can enjoy
their hobbies vacations or time spent
with family and hoarders are so intent
on building their money pile that they
may deprive themselves of important life
goals and experiences again what pushes
these behaviors into unhealthy territory
is that the activity is not pursued for
its own pleasures or benefits but as a
ritual to keep negative emotions at bay
lastly there are relational money
disorders disorders that involve close
relationships with spouses family and
friends
financial infidelity is the act of
deceiving one's partner about money
matters this can mean secret spending
and debts keeping a private bank account
or even stealing from each other
financial infidelity is often related to
other disorders like a spouse who has to
cover up debts resulting from compulsive
gambling financial enabling and
financial dependency are two sides of
one coin they refer to an unhealthy
relationship in which one person is
totally reliant on the other for all
their financial needs in accounting even
if they have the means to be independent
this is most often seen in parents who
continue to support an adult child who
takes no responsibility in their own
financial situation this is not to say
that people shouldn't help each other
out during tough times lord knows our
parents did it for us but if it's a
long-term recurring dynamic in which the
parent is sacrificing their own
retirement for a child who is not even
making a plan to become independent then
it may be fair to call the relationship
dysfunctional another relational
disorder is known as financial
enmeshment when a parent inappropriately
or unfairly involves a young child into
their financial hardship this can be
done to elicit sympathy to make the
child feel guilty for the cost they
incur or even to demean one's spouse in
the child's eyes if you recognize any of
these disorders in yourself or someone
close to you you may be wondering what
can be done about them anything so
connected to emotions has no easy fix
but there are some places to seek help
you can ask a spouse or other family
member to help manage the household's
money or you can use apps that schedule
and automate payments and investments
but that may not free you from the
trauma or anxiety that causes the
disorders in the first place there are a
lot of resources out there from books to
podcasts to help you identify your
emotions and not feel so alone but
talking with a professional like a
therapist or psychologist is often the
best way to support your financial and
emotional well-being
and that's our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
patron
if you want to sit in on our session
with a financial therapist check out our
video philip and julia go to therapy
you